Andthen,
good day, bikini fan, you
'll feel New York, go futvip, it
was the very warm Welcome to the
outstanding Person Clash of Clans
Android Spider started working on the stove
before that
And then another flame from Santo Antônio Player
pulled house and make  Easy Halloween It
Happen on
and vaccines São Paulo these makes a Week
and the way we don't look forward to put
your Foot Rope Belt for determination
Hi to our
rocket Raul Gil Kings rock you a portuguese
people
the act of guiding chest  Powers Of His
New estimation for talks with for Citrus
and above all with great at solidarity
in
I told The Beauty Of The Next
Generation of you on
and he knows how to move this one that they are friends and he
knows how to call Esposito that is that he
fell in love with players because  how come I do
n't see any which there are classes
teaching can say that the road the
digital Economy with never-before-seen
grindel reality and Within our society
is to be stronger and be moving on and
on
the outline was at home and it Billie Jean
the rose and free soft Race
and they go Lages stayed epacket NY Since
the Marshall plan here He is now and
fiction
I helped a very rare should Fight
Within the commission has and sire TV
screen Light Windows support  recovery
and Swan
e says spoke excellent population with
his works Under Control at the
commission division up to date in Portugal
handball Super Heroes batmobile with the
future with and Beyond by the portuguese
people on
The audio diversion bible Charles fome
Portugal Economy last remembered swim and
digital  transformation with funds and
investment if it's a smile I loved Portugal
EA bigger stronger furniture Alien and
oil the Ford Fusion
the suite in front of the flat or if by
some
WhatsApp schedule for me because I have the Time
Pilot scale energy Fashion Silva on the
bottom then furry or  Astro vinyl of the
King of apodi aggression or of Protests
will not use the reinforcement was 25 Years and
Direct protection in biodiversity
and walk through all this is not you in High
Elev soon a kiss Ah the next
Leandro marked to give utilization
the handball 55 percent in
the van didn't have But he since
in that one that was a certain using pencil
adversity I gave you must only have
warmed up  andrix ample and Velociraptor lives
we are international under cover
Under the Sun walk leave your like light flowers
molds at this time Cosmo Portugal
Hi antoniele from the plant Crisante Russo the
ippon if you live night already before the
burial of the weight on the cover sister to the one they
watch  ability of portuguese Public
finances
o this will make for arrive ramalde
Stronger Than ever before
o and shot the franchise limit of demand
and it will have the e fast Where is Elisa
leaves me eu said farsight the most
importantly the ball to View The
Question for play f*  ** by Visit to
and for your help in Union we could All
next in which you would have you ever so
much more than twenty Seven individuals
With or Without ever having It On
in our tr  ouble is a new horizons
Milestone pode Spears One of Six Strings
and seeks to your of the next one kaunis
on we would have stood at first the
first ones to Enjoy
Life from or dad didn't tell me like that
so now right so that's it from  hardware
small final templation of Portugal has
fish is in the present challenge and
child opportunity I Stand with you every
step of the way your success exhausted
Ajuru pinch them with fire dance now
your permission denied and How best to
you Antônio on behalf of your film
commission on  your National recovery and
splendid thank
thesky
Andthere
And there
I love to hear it cut live it doesn't answer
[Music]
there
And then
the guy great european commission offend
line and pizzeria Elisa Ferreira
varnish colleagues is for me
I want to see my special bring to be
today the opportunity to meet
presents resignation and receive from his
hands approval of the National Plan for
resilient recovery while
presidency of the Council of the European
Union health  commission and all
states see the path taken
throughout this
year everyone approved the decision that allowed
the european commission yesterday to realize the
first issuance of debt to
finance an economic recovery plan
many states agility of the
states have already presented their plans they
are maintaining  an intense work of
dialogue with all the services of
the european commission for this reason and it allows us to
arrive and celebrate one day today the
promotion of the first plans of
compression and resilience What is a
true milestone in the history of the European
Union
Hi today is the day  in which hope
turns to trust in the certainty that
it will be possible to launch an
ambitious and robust economic recovery
throughout the European Union
Europe rise to act together to
put the recovery in motion and in this way
we fulfill the way of our presidency
time  to act for a fair
green and digital recovery
in Portugal was the first country to
present its plan  that of recovery and
resilience and is today the first country to
have its plan approved, as the
president of the Commission said, this does not happen
by chance while the beginning of Portugal
will have to study hard all those who
were involved in the construction of this
recovery and resilience plan  there was a
huge participation of civil society and
I would like to leave a special word here
to Professor António Costa e Silva, who
stimulated the dialogue with civil society
and presented the strategic vision
on which we anchor this plan but also
the next multiannual financial framework
with which it is necessarily  in
padlock a word of great appreciation for
all Portuguese public management by
different members of the government and in all
of them president of the person add
simultaneously I'm not it
's a great effort the public campus has
made for the construction of this plan and
I want to underline the unique process of
participation  at a national level but also
the customer relationship that was possible
es  establish with the european commission with
the different services of the
european commission And create here, in addition to
thanking the president of the commission, give
a very special word to commissioner
Paulo addizione and vice president
Valdir dombroski Easy who were
directly involved in this whole process
and now  now it is also time to act
this time internally here in Portugal
to implement this Plan A,
ensuring not only the recovery but
above all the transformation of our country
increasing our
enlightening growth potential Barriers to
our Progress guaranteeing a
more competitive economy more
productive companies more  and better decent employment
with rights,
and there is no doubt
that the European Commission clearly underlines that this is
an ambitious plan and a
lasting and significant transformation in our
economy and in our social environment
throughout the territory and in the lives of the
Portuguese This is not a  plan just to
respond to the pain of this crisis This is a
p  plan to allow us to go faster and
further in the convergence with the European
Union but this is above all also a
plan to change the day-to-day life of the
Portuguese with a
stronger National Health Service with more
affordable housing with fewer inequalities and  with a
better quality of life for our
elderly
we are recovering from the effects of
the pandemic crisis but we also have to
build a country that is more resilient
and with our eyes on future
generations so we are strategically betting on
forests or the sea and taking
climate action  The digital transition as
engines of our development as
we are today truly
building our future and this living science school
that we visit today is the symbol of
that strategic vision, betting on
knowledge based on a
more innovative country closer and fairer to a
country that  we want to build for the
next generations and we do justice to the
name of this program, right Generation you
go what in our  the plan we have a
very clear objective
is the zombie of living science schools
that we have that the country we have to increase
fervently and of the 237 clubs of
living science existing in schools across the
country we are going to add More 650 Club
we want to build a new generation more
awakens patience  more motivated
patience more committed to
knowledge more creative more
innovative and able to drive
a country that is increasingly
closer now to fully materialize
the opportunities of this
recovery and resilience plan it is essential
to mobilize everyone This is a
work  to be developed in
partnership and is a network work it is a
work with the autonomous regions with the
other local guides
the special consultant the mercies
Municipality of ipss butcher our
scientific and technological system two
companies and drivers the citizen we know
very well dear Úrsula that the  hard work
begins to truly now we will be
with demanding work  and that this plan
does not have an execution system identical
to what is traditional in community funds
the plan is not a blank check
with this plan it is a commitment that has
goals that have goals and that have
timetables we know well we have to
meet these goals had  Fulfilling these
objectives told me for us is not a
difficulty But it is a necessary motivation
to effectively accomplish
what We agreed today with the
European Commission and that is why we are already
working with all national partners
to start implementing
this recovery plan  and resilience
and we want to launch many of these
instruments in the next few days
we were the first to see the plan for
recovery and violence approved is
an honor for us and above all it is a
huge responsibility for us for this
after having been the first terms to be
also the  better in realizing
their full potential by rebuilding a
future that is robust Digital green
that doesn't  I don't leave anyone behind and that
is focused on the next generations Thank
you very much Once again for the way we
worked together in the design and
approval of this plan and it is between us an
honorable commitment to give the best
education thank you very much guys
[Applause
] Pedro  Sacadura here is a question for
the previous president chemistry small pieces
of international order Harry drag the
box All ceramic transformation
and recovery in both his Hand and the
next step in the process to the help
board at YouTube here it was not at the other
end Kutcher At Last  Week we were Lucky
and love you thank you very good
cooperation of portuguese presidency is
a Youth hostel World of member States
have failed de ouro e sua assistants
sou da commission for our Yesterday
Gaucho da capital markets and
o husband Extreme successful with Richie
Campbell generous with  Seven times over
is written everything existed before it says
neither the owner a on the merit the bag is still
bad but the pants r  osa gross Weekend first
ever Since the world and IV
and here give mass aniquest anal f***
protected stay took the opportunity to
ask then in Portuguese what is the
nature of the priority projects to
be analyzed and placed under
our program has three
fundamental pillars o  strengthening resilience
climate action and the digital transition in
the audience forces the priority of
the national health service
secondly to make housing more
affordable instead increase the
productive potential of our economy and
fourthly to reduce inequalities and
strengthen territorial cohesion  and social
of our country nation climate private
are clear in mobility energy in
energy efficiency and in the valorization
of the oceans are a great
climate regulator in digital transmission the
great bet we have is in the formation
of new generations
the purification of Generations
active creation for the economy of the world  future and for
also and for also Finally an
association  more efficient more
modern public action that is not a
bureaucratic barrier to entrepreneurship bureaucratic barrier to
the functioning of companies
and contributes to improving the
competitiveness of our economy to
attract foreign direct
investment and to improve the
productivity of our companies teaching
these are the  our priorities is
Andthere
to retain more Fonseca sometimes glasses is the
first question of an economic order the
first funds for the prr only brain be
deprived made available in August
which it is pointed out that it will have a
smaller impact than expected on Sic in this
different economies  in 2022 whether the
prospects for economic growth in the
European Union are
much lower than those of the United
States or China teach the pastor
concern and rebalancing this
very bureaucratic meters of
approval within the European Union second
issue is the possibility of anticipation
of digital certificate p  for a trip the
possibility of anticipation the yay what
experiences being president of
the european commission that the stairs to
lisbon and the possibility of being with people
options with countries
like unisys united states that are
essential for tourism europa.eu it
's just the party there  comes with black On
Black Fashion ah ah ah sorry how
this Next Generation and the team Black or
White remember the rain change eagle the App
Store but we have to Legendary Ford is
so much at End of Words and Electric
Energy we got not only two Beauty  of the
road from now on I have friends and a
very ambitious plans but also to be able
to father I don't use to provide - 6 to 9 m of
marketing Joyce made me feel Black
Out at the investment willingness it could
be me and the exam  expressly nas é o
ideal carnaval device with us your
opinion it we have to do to be her with
your name on it if we look at for
example the Channel Sky Cross stayed
here we come to the future when
experiment the Queen instrument  ntos
Complex hybridization of working and
Next Generation you and head out To The
American Plants presented lower The
Vampire not at home on if you don’t at
time of your sweete win32 Joaquim And
investment and I will be waiting for
some of the deep and American
And then Henry Cavill and president of Deep
so I very much online under General
manda stand-in' on the outside of
Atlantic treaty with lessons from the
Life He is the big five Nights at
freddy's free course not full back from the
factory Facebook Sabor remote Jolie  to
leave but Stay with full support and at
your Mercy
and I think that we cannot confuse
the crisis emergency response instruments
with those problems that have a
nature not only of an immediate response to the
crisis but above all have a transforming power and
vocation  regarding the
future of the meal very
quick to respond to the crisis response in the
first few months of getting to know the ugly the
European Central Bank council
took decisions  definitive measures to
stabilize the markets to
provide the states with financing lines such
as rains for were
indispensable to maintain the employment
received in Portugal through the
delay off measures and also to create an
emergency line for the states
unfortunately none of them had to be
used until now for a
what we have to do today
with the approval of this plan is something that has
a historical dimension in the European Union.
that the very strong reaction of
the european commission forced the council to
act and despite having taken 5 days and
4 nights to have managed not only to
unlock what was blocked on
the next financial framework until 2030
but also to have several problems with a historical nature it
is the first time that  the
commission that the European Union responds to
as the Augusto do  From a budgetary point of view
and at a time when the
European Central Bank had already forgotten several times
that it had run
out of monetary policy capacity
to sustain growth
and that it was necessary to have an instrumental
instrument This is not the first time they
wanted instrumental instruments  to
respond to the crisis and it is with an instrument that
is already weak announced by resources
the issuance of debt by the commission that
started yesterday and that will allow the States as a
whole
the power to recover and present we
have to understand that they are
essential if the money arrives this
week  your money will arrive in
august Of course the more to have it
get better now these plans or at
least our plan is not designed
for a 100 meters race it is
designed to be a wounded of a cost
to have a profound transforming power
in our  city and not simply to respo
d to what are the immed
ate needs of the crisis to  go we have other
instruments and we have other
mechanisms just this week the european central bank
made an upward review of
televisions growth in the european union
don't be bank portugal has already announced Or
people go with predictions about the
growth of the portuguese economy but
i'm convinced it will follow
what the European Central Bank's forecasts are
and therefore we have to use and
think about
the plans mainly for this vision of the
future when the digital certificate
and it enters into force throughout the European
Union on the next 1st of July was
also an initiative of the  commission it was
possible to announce with European problems
in record time that it took 62 days
for the presentation of the proposal and
approval by the council that the
European Parliament and the states are starting to
use it on an experimental and
provisional basis today the commission must
present a commission  you can now enter
Portugal and I came from your
digital and dangerous certificate that the brain  ro
is able to apply
digital tickets that are presented and
today the National Health Service
will start issuing the first
digital certificates for Portuguese citizens
and from tomorrow
the possibility of each one to
request their digital certificate will be available on the SMS website
which opens the opportunity for the government to
use this certificate not only for the
purpose of entering and leaving the borders
but also for other purposes,
namely so that weddings and
other similar events can be carried
out safely without the need for
additional tests for those who already have it.  from the
digital certificate
Hi good afternoon Sérgio Vicente from RTP
sir first we
took my colleague's question had Morais Fonseca
just wanted to clarify what happened
to the president of Luz raise Lan
today the arrival can now happen to
any European citizen has a
vaccination certificate  of the
digital vaccination certificate this is a  the issue
that was we still have preference in
relation to the recovery and
resilience plan to a group of
international investors who are calling into question the
financing of this European plan
due to an internal
Portuguese issue and I agree with the solution of
the Espírito Santo bank they say that  they want to
be used in two billion euros
and they want to condition that
hello good is with levels above 240
240 cases per 100 thousand inhabitants Look, only
after two evaluations above 240 is
that Lisbon should back off not understanding the
prime minister are accurate in  lives
lead from a certain fear of taking
measures in advance before
starting before reaching
240 twice And to finish this first one is
focused on the selection as president of the
republic Thank you very much to
and after going to form in this Antônio
Reis Álvaro Mendes And  certification and
Foot cover and reptiles and The Good
News is a software they have heard
fifteen member state Park  Connection
Life volume history and power Line
pattern is the first of your life London
School of fish live on Going and quick
load All member States will have link
aptitude certificate saudade with
similar problems with iFood Speed way you l
e you lie you are Cold and showed that
I
and the present systems in relation to
the pilot phase we have to test it and we will
start from because it is with the president
of the European Commission we will extend this
test phase and your signaling both
at the limit on the 1st of July will be
in effect throughout  at all
entry points is my conviction in restaurants
but that I don't like to make
commitments that a cat can't after
and surely by July they
will all be and I know that in this world they
are already being sent by SMS
pulls digital and that  from
tomorrow people will be able to
start laughing on the website of the
National Health Service issuing their
digital certificate on these
investors from the cradle I don't know  it refers,
therefore, I don't know you personally
about this matter as to what it
is worth if we start we do weekly
the council of ministers and evaluation of
the arresting situation and that in each of the
councils and next Thursday
present Tomorrow we will again have the
evaluation and evolution of the evaluation  what
we have done we will take the necessary measures
we have built a matrix that has two
fundamental indicators it does not have to do
with the incidence rate or if it has to do
with the transmission rate through the
pastor r.r.  and depending on these
variations we apply the measures that are
foreseen to each council and all
councils are the same for this purpose and
therefore the good one will not be different from the
other councils and brings exactly the
same treatment as other councils
Finally as usual the
Prime Minister and the President of the
Republic are totally in tune and
naturally it has around the selection of
the Portuguese national team where your present
could vibrate
in Rua Vitória de Portugal and you could
vibrate through the television next
Saturday we will exchange positions I will
suffer in Munich  the game with Germany
the president I hope that
Portugal's results
in Munich are on television But you're in tune with
the national team's engine
and you have to take a
Hey Hey
HeyHey
[Music]